hi everyone thanks for calling me my
name is jin i am a data scientist today
i want to talk about fuguting a simple
interface for distributed hyperparameter
tuning
tune is an abstraction layer for general
hyperparameter tuning
it has integrated existing
hyperparameter tuning frameworks such as
obtuna and hyperopt
and provided a scalable and simple
interface on top of them
field is a unified layer for distributed
computing that lets users execute python
pandas and sql code on parallel
computing tools such as spark and desk
without any regrets
tune is built on field so it can
seamlessly run on any back end supported
by field
and both tune and field are open sourced
so you can install them with pip install
tune and pip instant fuel
in today's presentation i will first
give an introduction to the hyper
parameter tuning problem in machine
learning and discuss some common
pinpoints from a data scientist point of
view
then i'll talk about how those pain
points are addressed by fuktum i walk
you through some basic usages and
feature highlights
i'll demo on customizing hybrid search
spaces and show you a real use case on
tuning a forecasting model distributedly
first let's talk about the problem of
hyper parameter tuning in machine
learning
hepa primary tuning plays a critical
role in machine learning workflow
almost every model in industry today has
hyper parameters that must be set in
order to customize the model to a
specific problem and the data set
the essence of hyper parameter
optimization is simple
from a search space we want to find a
set of have a parameters that can
maximize or minimize some machine
learning objective function
which is a function that trains the
model with each input hyperparameter
combination and output some modal score
from the validation data set
however implementing such a
straightforward tuning flow could be
cumbersome
let me give you a concrete example that
is common in every modal developer's
work
the problem is super simple yet there's
no elegant solution so far
han is working on the california housing
prediction problem on kegel and by the
way han is the creator of this tune
library
had looked over the discussion board and
noticed that many people are using x-ray
boost and led gbm
so he decided to try both and take the
best results
this is very common in our everyday work
right
because xj boost takes a longer time to
train hand decided to use research on
x-ray boost
and patient optimization on that gbm
i'll pause here for a second and let's
think together if your hand how would
you design this search space
or this entire tuning flow
i will think out loud here first no
matter what tuning framework to use we
will need to define an objective
function to optimize
in this problem
i need a function that trains and
cross-validates the model and output a
matrix score to measure the model
performance on each hyper-parameter set
then is to define a search space
intuitively i need a search space for x3
boost where i do grade search
then another search base for like gbm is
where i do basic optimization
then i'll use some optimizer to search
over the union of these two spaces to
get the best results
this is super easy and simple right
now let's code it
as you can see even using the simplest
existing tuning interface of tuna
the code will be this long
this is because one different tuning
methods are exclusive to each other
so users need to define separate
objective functions to use more than one
method
and two to do research parameters have
to be declared twice
and in different ways
but going back to the original problem
all we want to do is just this little
piece
couldn't there be
a simple and elegant approach
let me introduce fieldtune's solution
on the left side we have the code
defining the search space and
optimization flow using
obtuna on the right side is field two's
code
note that in tune's approach we also use
the obtuna for basic optimization
so these two code snippets are doing
exactly the same thing but we can see
that qscode is much simpler and more
intuitive
in tune model search grade search random
search and basic optimization can be
combined intuitively into one space
using simple operators
in this example we use the plus operator
and there is zero redundancy on defining
any parameters
so what makes tune's interface so simple
the secret is in tune's definition of
search space
graysearch is the most commonly used
tuning method
it exhaustively searches through a set
of user-specified hyper-parameter
choices
the result is deterministic
so it's good for categorical parameters
such as modeling methods
or whatever we want to make sure to
traverse all the options
however it is extremely inefficient
the computational complexity increases
exponentially with the number of
parameters
in in tune grade search is defined using
the keyword grade
random search on the other hand give
users the control on the number of total
iterations
it can outperform grade search
especially when only a small number of
hyper parameters is affecting the final
model performance
however because each guess is
independent from the previous one
it normally requires a large number of
samples to achieve a good result
which may be limited by time and
resources
in tune random search is defined using
the keyword rent and choice with a
specified number of samples
a third well adopted tuning method is
basic optimization
different from random sampling patient
optimization builds a probabilistic
surrogate model for the hyperparameter
itself
and iteratively makes the next guess
based on the previous observations
it was proven to be able to achieve a
better result in fewer iterations
however its sequential process cannot be
distributed so actually may take a
longer time to finish
and in tune basian optimization is
defined using the same keyword as random
search without specifying the number of
samples
now comes the amazing part
putting different type of spaces
together
tune allows users to define hybrid
search space using simple operations
in this example we are doing random
search on parameter a
great search on parameter b we used a
plus operator to take the union of these
two
these two search spaces
we also define the bayesian optimization
space for parameter c
and multiply that to the union of random
search and research
in this way the bayesian optimization
will be applied as a second layer of
optimization
to the generated research and random
search
we can see in the generated search space
we have two samples for a by true by
randomly choosing two samples in a given
range
to sample for b
from a research of two options all of
them followed by a bayesian optimization
on parameter c
it's okay if you haven't fully got this
idea yet let's do some quick demo on
space operations to get a better
understanding
starting from one similar to the
california housing example
we are trying to tune three model
together using different
algorithms
and different tuning method
in tune we just need to define three
space each of which with different model
different method
and putting them together using the plus
operator
to get a union of this search space
in the generated search space we can see
that
we have two samples for xg boost
they're coming from a grade search
on two options
we have three samples for elec gbm
they're coming from randomly
choose three samples in the given range
and lastly we have one sample for
catboost
for basic optimization
in the next example let's see what if we
want to
apply different tuning method in one
model
here we are using lgbm
but we want to do great search on the
boosting method
random search on the fraction on the
feature fraction
and basia optimization on the learning
rate
to achieve this we just need to define
the bayesian optimization space
separately because we don't want to
give it a specified number of samples
then putting them together
simply using the star operator to take
the cross product
of these two space
and in the generated space
we can see that we have
four samples
because we have a great search of two
options
and the random search of two samples
that's two by two a cross product of two
by two and all of them
followed by a basic optimization on the
learning rate
and lastly let's see how to put them
together
assume now we still want to
try
different modeling method
but this time we want to do basic
optimization on the common parameter and
estimators
in tune you don't need to repeat the
code three times
but you can simply multiply the basic
optimization space
to the union
of the three modal space
and you will get this
search space where you have three
samples each of which has a different
modeling method
and a basic optimization applied to the
estimators
now we have understood the most
important concept of field 2 search
space
let's talk about another key and amazing
part
distributed hyper parameter tuning
flexibility and simplicity
of a space definition is just a startup
tune
with field we can easily distribute the
tuning drops to thousands of machines
and ran them parallelly
assume now we want to try both fully
grade search and a hybrid space
and
together
and there's gonna be a lot of
evaluations
but with field we could easily
distribute the drops
and let's see how easy it is
all we need to do is to specify the
execution engine in the suggested method
and field will take care of old backend
logics
users do not need to write any spark
code or dash code nor do they need to
know spark or desk at all
in addition
it is important to monitor the tuning
process in real time
this again can be achieved with field to
simple interface by customizing
parameters
today tune has two built-in monitoring
methods best metric and histogram of
metrics
both are represented using a simple
string
and users can also customize their own
monitors
we have covered a lot so far
but there are still many other great
functionalities of two i would like to
call out so i picked three of my
favorite ones to share today
first one unlike other existing tuning
libraries that require the objective
function to be defined in a certain way
tune takes native python functions as
objectives
that means users do not need to onboard
any new objective framework
and could pass in any parameters they
want to customize their tuning flow
second and also my most favorite one
two makes a tree view to get associate
matrix from metadata
sometimes we want to track multiple
modal scores in each iteration like map
and mean absolute error in this case
this simple task turns out to be
non-trivial using existing libraries
like optional
but in tune all you need to do is to
change the output annotation to a tuple
of float and dictionary
and you will be able to get all the
metadata from the result of the
suggested method
last but not least
great search and random search are
naturally handled by team distributedly
in those two cases no extra local
optimizer is needed
if one wants to do advanced tuning with
facial optimization
tune has unified expressions for other
grid frameworks such as obtuna and
hyperopt
and allow users to switch between them
seamlessly
in changing one parameter
at the end let's take a break and check
out one interesting use case of fukutun
a forecasting problem using the grey cat
model
greycat is a time series forecasting
library developed by linkedin
and of course in python language
we choose graycats to do the demo for
tune is because it's a fairly new open
source library
meaning a new look of objectives
in this example we're forecasting the
number of weekly daily log page views
for one of the greatest football
quarterback player
peyton manning
the data frame contains daily data
ranges from 2007 to 2016.
it has two columns
a time column ts
and the value column 1.
the data value ranges from 5 to 12 and
the model will be trained and evaluated
using time series cross validation
and the last year of the data was
reserved as the testing set where the
primary metric we're going to use is the
map
recap is an additive model so it's very
very flexible on customizing parameters
here's a list of some common parameter
types in gridcad
their daytime derivatives
growth trend seasonalities
events like holidays and in this case
super bowl
dates so now let's take a look of the
tuning code
this demo means to
show you a complex objective and a large
tuning space
so you do not have to read over each
line i will highlight
the parts that is related to our topic
so here we define the objective function
for this forecasting model
as you can see
it is very detail oriented
because of greek has flexibility
but that is totally fine
user can customize their objective
function
in any way they want
all we need is an output of the model
score
that will be used to evaluate the model
and two will convert the rest to be
tuned compatible
and here notice how easy to get the
metadata
and then let's take a look of the search
space
as we can see again there are many
parameters we can play with
in this forecasting model
but that's also fine with toons
interface
even if we want to do mixed type of
tuning methods for example we used
um
station optimization
for regular radiation strength in this
change point detection algorithm and we
used a great search
for the number of days before and after
a holiday to count separately
we can still define the whole search
space
in an elegant way
we define 25 parameters here
and most importantly
encoding one function
we can easily distribute the job and run
it parallelly
and in just 10 minutes
we can get a modal score of 4.5
comparing to a 7.3 on greek has official
dock to summarize today's presentation
we have covered three major parts of
fieldtune
the definition of search space
distributed hyperparameter tuning
and grid feature highlights
and
tune is
library
that is framework and method agnostic
skillable and automated
it's also platform agnostic
so if you find today's
content interesting i highly encourage
you to try it out
again you can install it immediately
with pip install
on your machine
that'll be the last style of today's
presentation
all the demo notebooks we went over
today are available on kegel please feel
free to check them out
and thank you so much for listening i'm
not happy to answer any questions
all right so thank you very much er
generally you we still have like five
minutes left
i also want to thank your collaborator
me someone for
helping us with some questions
asked by our participants
so maybe
we can extend a little bit of
explanation if you think it's fine like
ky was asking for example what you need
to distribute a tune with spark can we
use multiple spark sessions at the same
time
thanks marcelo let me go back to this
slide here
oops
to distribute to on spark you just need
to get your spark session and represent
it using a string
and then field will take over all the
backhand
logic
so you do not need to write any code you
just need to represent your spark
session using a customized string here
it doesn't need to be spark but any
customized string and you don't need to
worry about all the
logics behind that
all right
there's another question by another
participant
he or she is asking if this algorithm
can work
within pytorch or tensorflow can it work
in both of them
great question
of course yes it's a general tuning
method works for general objective
functions you may notice that let's
still use this slide you may notice that
the suggested method we use here is
called suggest for a non-iterative
objective
that means for a non-iterative objective
means objective that run once to get the
result so they don't need to output
information in the middle of this
iteration to this to do any say pruning
decisions like deep learning
works deep learning frameworks
we also have suggests for iterative
objectives they are designed for deep
learning frameworks
feel free to check them out all right
there's another question from ese
from the great kite example did you did
you use bo for most of the continuous
variables
is 10 minutes the total run time for
tuning all the parameter combinations
thank you for that question uh that's
two questions i'll answer them uh i'll
start first one yes we used
uh basic optimization
for
not all the older parameters it's a
subset of parameters because greatcat
has so many parameters we can play with
the list can go and
can go forever here you can see here we
did
uh
for base optimization
you can simply switch to
random by adding
by specifying a number of samples
if we do not if you do not specify a
number of samples that would be a
bayesian optimization for any parameter
with the search space defined by rent
and the second question is
uh
i'm sorry the second is about the
time taken
uh marcelo can repeat the question
oh sure i'm going to repeat it
so the second question is
is 10 minutes the total run time for
tuning all of the parameter combinations
yep
um that's such a great question uh not
necessarily because we have distributed
the process
so if and we have the early stopping
so if we have triggered early stopping
we probably won't traverse all the
combinations and the 10 minutes is uh
using
four workers running parallel together
thanks for that question that's all
right i think there are two last
questions uh one of them is simple the
other one is regarding a kaggle
well
yeah well it's
actually a comment from a han mentioning
that on kaggle with limited
computational resource it's better it's
a better idea to use grid plus bo
so maybe you could explain a little bit
about the bo resource if it's possible
um
yeah i get kyle's point because basia
optimization let me go back to that
slide
facial optimization is a iterative
process
it's so it's well
every second guess is depending on the
completion of the first iteration of its
previous iteration
so it usually takes a longer time
so with with kegel um
sorry
it's the question why we apply basin on
live gbm and
random and grade on x-ray boost
i guess so so because extreme boost in
general uh
requires a longer training time so if we
want them to finish in roughly the same
amount of time to get the best results
we want to pair a faster modeling method
with the slower training method and
slower modeling method with a faster
training faster tuning method
that's all right june so unfortunately
oh
i also see a question from e uh it's a
simple question how could you address it
whether the order of the space is matter
it doesn't matter
you can customize it in any order all
right so i want to thank you a very much
for all
attendees for your questions
unfortunately we are running out of time
i want to thank you so much for your
amazing presentation john